somebody told me recently like when
they're on a Southwest flight they fight
but they're not actually fight that's G
but don't sit like aisle and window and
then they'll just start fighting so that
no one sits in the middle of them you
know you have to make the fight about
double booking something that's kind of
important yeah you're like is this your
is this your brother-in-law I
don't even like that guy yes like in-law
related yeah like I'm I'm
not gonna go why are we going for five
days yeah why I could just weird
people out because they walk by just
not even in a sexual way just like a
H you smell nice yeah
someone's walking up to you
yeah once you're sitting here man
all right no thanks yeah you should
invite people yeah yeah yeah yo yo get
in here man ah you should you should sit
here nice pants nice pants nice
pants you want to sit beside me nice ass
I'm gonna sit there man nice try ah
how do you know